welcome back everybody my next guest is
a four-time Grammy winning recording
artist that's four okay I'm Hoover
encouraged all the independent women out
there to put their hands up now she's a
mom has new music and she's on a mission
to raise awareness about how hard the
african-american community has been hit
by coving my team let's say hi to Kelly
Rowland what's up Kelly first of all I
love your son Kelly I Jam to it all the
time Kelly obviously but I'm just I love
that song I'm trying to figure out a way
to cover it on my show without looking
stupid but I love I just love that song
it's so great but I do want to get to
why you want to talk here today it's
important to me as well actually my
house manager my one of my really good
friends
Ava we've been talking about this
because she's in LA holding our house
down for us and I'm like don't go out
cuz they worse for african-americans and
and where are you right now and how is
crunching going for you though
quarantine is going good and you're
actually absolutely spot-on right Kelly
it's it's um you know it's funny when
you start to think about the ratio and
population of black people we only make
up 13% which of course makes this
minority but it's 33% of Kovach patients
are african-american and some of them
were african-american because of course
you know the virus comes and it's so
many different types and I don't it's
just so mind-blowing but 13 that's a big
number 33 percent of patients are
african-american and we have to get that
number down and I don't know what's
making people feel like either it can't
happen to them whether they're an
african-american community or not but
you have to take this seriously because
you know one thing happens like right
after another which is oh you go out
your friend has it your friend gives it
to you you give it to Grandma then I tea
then this person did those people give
it to someone else that's how it spread
so fast and we just have to take this
way more seriously you got to think
about also the the illnesses from high
blood pressure high cholesterol
hypertension
and asthma so many different illnesses
that have been really generational you
know illnesses in the african-american
community makes it worse
yeah yeah so what you know is we just
want to be smart about all this and I
just really want to encourage everyone
to stay inside we're not quite done with
this but we can be if we really practice
our social distancing and have I'd like
to say kindness because when you
actually approach this with kindness
then you'll think about the fact that I
don't want this to happen to me and let
me just be kind stay in my home and be
smart about all of this do you have an
okay immune system maybe you might be
fine but first of all I do love a level
of invincibility people think they're
invincible like they watch and they're
like oh that happens to someone else I'm
like you could be that someone else
really it's just it's a it's a crazy
time right now but you're in quarantine
for me coming back to your question has
been nuts because you know we have three
kids with us right now are 18 year olds
in Florida but we have a lot of kids a
lot of homework a lot of cook and lot of
still working in a really hard go I'm
not gonna lie there's not a self-help
book in the world that can help my
psyche last week how is yours going is
yours nuts it's going good like
literally you probably hear tight in the
back on the zone call with his classroom
he's right in there watch a Mickey Mouse
oh it's real so between that and he's
the only child I do want to have another
one so bad but you know he's by himself
so he expects my attention at home time
which is colored overwhelming and I
still have work to do and putting out
music and finishing up literally
finishing up an album which on their
exact cannot wait to can we out of
warranty and I'd love to play you some
records but it's just really I feel bad
for him because I also had to think
about the fact that the same way I'm
trying to think about all this and like
flush all of these thoughts out so is he
so it's like the most random time
the day he'll just act out and then I'll
hone in on him and like look at him and
then I know like plate therapy works
with him so like we'll stop playing with
cars and after a while I'm like do you
know why you got so upset like and then
he'll tell me why and he's like I miss
my friends and I want to go to school
yeah it's the same so they're they're
trying to like figure out what's going
on with them too it's just you have to
have some patience with these babies
I hunted percent agree but let's talk
about one of your other passions and
congrats on is your new single coffee
and then you have an Instagram live show
right called coffee with telly
we're so naughty on the show in a good
way because like like you just said like
prior persons likes it shipping gears
we're all bombarded with so much
coronavirus statistics and facts and new
information every day to where it kind
of soaks up everything that we are and
consumes us and brings forth anxiety and
that's what it was doing to me and I was
like I have to break this up so I came
up with coffee with Kelly and it's just
literally us having like talking sex and
kinky stuff and just have it go exactly
so it definitely brings a light and we
have a really good time yesterday we
were talking about relationships and
Quarantine and you know I keep saying
this I keep going man either there's a
lot of babies are gonna come out of this
and a lot of divorces because we're
always around each other all the time I
love that though I love that's it that's
it and I don't know if it's a Kelly
thing but I love the fact that you are
very open or a Texas thing but it's
you're very open and raw and real and I
mean you know you're like oh we get NASA
I'm like yeah I'm like everybody
you know this way you know approach all
those the subject tonight I think it's
awesome and I think it's really
important to have not just stiff content
and I think it's you know to have real
raw content as real conversations I
think is cool and congratulations on
that it's it's awesome thank you so much
I've always been a fan I'm such a big
fan of you but I just want to say thank
you and I want everybody to check out
Kelly's new show coffee with Kelly and I
Instagram as well as her new single
coffee y'all better get that subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going